hello and welcome to pi data global 2021
my name is tanya i'm your moderator for
the session
and please if you feel comfortable in
doing so rename yourself
to the name you would like to be called
in the session and if you want to also
add your pronouns so we can address you
properly if you ask any questions
please note we are recording the session
so you can have a look at it afterwards
if you've missed something or just want
to have another look at it
so
our workshop today has the title data
processing at scale and i will just
quickly introduce the group of speakers
to you and then we can get started
so we have benjamin zeitlin who's system
software manager at nvidia and a long
time contributor to the python and pi
data ecosystem we have james bobu who's
lead open source engineer at coiled and
we'll have a talk tomorrow about
snowflake and task
martin duran who's a former
astrophysicist data scientist and
medical imaging imaging researcher and
now open source contributor and
community advocate who has a talk later
today titled or you need a czar at 7 pm
utc
we have matthew powers tech evangelist
at coiled also author of two books and
the popular blog
and he had a talk yesterday about why
pocket files are better than csv so you
can check the recording of this
and last but not least we have richard
zamora senior systems software engineer
at nvidia and also frequent contributor
to the dusk data frame so guys this
stage is yours have fun
tonya um
again my name's ben i'm gonna
share my screen throughout this
presentation so people want to move back
and forth let me know yeah so as tanya
said we're going to be talking about
data processing at scale um
we
all of us are contributors to pi data to
the desk ecosystem and we work at three
different companies at nvidia coiled and
anaconda and it's really great that all
of us can continue collaborating around
a really crucial piece of software
all right so
um so you have this nice kind of single
single line sentence here high
performance isn't about doing one thing
well it's about doing nothing poorly so
as
anybody kind of goes down the path of
either high performance computing or
scaling their application
they'll find that
as they solve one problem they'll hit
another they first go down the path of
i need my compute to be as fast as
possible and they start
maybe making
chips faster and then as you start
connecting many machines together you'll
find that
network communication actually becomes a
problem and as you explore faster
network communication you'll find oh
actually my application is dependent on
getting loading data from from disk as
fast as possible onto the
um onto the cpu or gpu or tpu um so we
really have to think about how to make
all these things kind of work in harmony
together and not any one of them kind of
overrides overrides another one
so we're mostly going to be in this talk
we're mostly going to be focusing on
um
cloud parts uh
around kind of pulling data from from
data stores like s3 or um
or more newer technologies like delta
lake or or iceberg
and thinking about how to
get das to work with these larger
systems or how das can
leverage
other
binary formats rk and do as little work
as possible to give the best throughput
for for a given workflow
um so here's kind of a brief overview of
the talk where we've segmented it around
our faces
um though not our names
um
so maybe we can kick it over to matt
powers just to
start us off on why what the kind of
problems that we hit at scale which look
very different than running on a single
machine uh and motivate why we've been
improving or the kinds of improvements
that we've pushed into desk and the
larger pi data ecosystem
maybe you want to introduce yourself and
and
move on
uh sure thing sounds great so my name is
uh matthew powers i um used to work in
spark for around seven years uh recently
switched over to the desk side of things
i've been loving desk i think that i'm a
big huge fanboy of both spark and desk
but love and desk so far and uh really
excited to show you some
cool developments and recent
improvements in desk so uh next slide
please
um so
what's really cool about desk right now
is it's become a great uh option for etl
so desk plays very nicely with a variety
of systems it has great parque support
and it can interact with lots of
different types of databases
so i'm going to talk about desk at a
high level kind of cluster computing at
a high level and i'll be passing it off
to some of the other folks for more
detailed dives
rick is going to give a good overview of
desk and then talk about the parquet
stuff in particular
james is going to talk about when we do
huge scaling what type of additional
challenges we run into like that as we
go from one terabyte to 100 terabytes
and then martin is going to chat about
other ecosystem improvements so it's
it's going to be a great talk a lot of
these guys are my kind of code idols i
see them on pull requests and stuff like
that i just kind of am in all of their
code so uh kind of nervous giving them
the introduction and honored
next slide please
so uh
this this slide is to kind of motivate
why we care about etl
and kind of this kind of more more the
boring stuff and not the cool ml stuff
and
this is an image from a google study and
each box represents how much time was
spent on different tasks in building a
production grid ml system and we can see
that in that little box in the middle
that was the actual ml code part and
then these other boxes like data
collection verification monitoring
service you know servers that was the
majority of the time was spent on that
and in in the real world when you're
building these systems the etl stuff is
really important in solving the cool
ml problems that you want to get to
so that's part of the reason why we've
devoted a lot of resources to making etl
awesome with a desk
um next slide please
so this is just kind of a high level
diagram showing the type of etl we can
do with desk so
it's no problem to read a bunch of csv
files do some filtering transformations
aggregations
write out some parquet files and then
perhaps visualize those on a dashboard
so
desk is a great uh option for these type
of
etl workflows
uh next slide please
so another thing that's great about desk
is it has great interop with other types
of systems so let's suppose you have a
spark etl pipeline
and you're reading in csv files and
doing a bunch of transformations and
writing out parque
now those parque files can easily be
read into a das cluster to train a
machine learning model so you can kind
of pick and choose and compose your etl
pipelines
and you know put desk in there when it
makes the most sense um we see a lot of
people love doing this when they're like
oh yeah we want to use you know desks
that that model that desk provides easy
access to so they just kind of jump in
there
and read in some parque files that were
outputted by another system
next slide please
so another thing that's great about desk
is it can read in data from a variety of
different types of databases so we have
connectors for
snowflake uh the bigquery one is in
development and the mongodb one exists
i think james is going to talk about the
snowflake one tomorrow that's a really
cool connector because it has
parallel i o so it's super fast um
next slide please
okay so shifting modes a little bit in
this talk we're going to be chatting a
lot about the parquet file format the
parkit file format has become probably
the most important file format in the
big data space
for a variety of reasons so we're going
to talk about it at a very low level as
we should because we're going to be
getting talks directly from these core
and developers who are doing this low
level work and before we wanted to
before we dive into the low level stuff
i just wanted to cover some high level
benefits of parquet
just so there's some higher level
context
so
at a high level uh parque gives us some
really nice benefits like there's the
schema in the file footer so we don't
need to infer it
it's a columnar file format which means
it's more compressible and results in
smaller file sizes
column number file formats
also allow for column pruning which in
cluster environments can be a huge
performance gain
parquet files organize data in row
groups
which has metadata
and allows for predicate push down
filtering
and all of these
parquet features are fully supported in
desk so you can take full advantage of
them
next slide please
so this uh little diagram here showing
you know comparing kind of csvs and
parquet files with the schema so right
if you have a csv file you either need
to infer the schema or manually specify
it
both of those are potentially
computationally expensive they're
annoying they're error prone who wants
to do that
with parquet files we can just grab the
schema
from the file footer or potentially from
a metadata file
we'll be talking a lot about grabbing
schemas from parquet files so it's good
to have this intuition that in parquet
files the schema exists in the file
footer metadata
uh next slide please
this is this slide's trying to give you
some intuition on the difference between
row based file formats and column their
file formats
so row base file formats stores data in
rows
column or file formats are kind of like
a transposed version of a row based file
format
and one cool thing about columnar file
formats is that they store similar types
closer to each other uh compression
algorithm algorithms really like that
and that's why
uh columnar files uh like parquet are
more compressible than row base file
formats like csv
next slide please
another amazing benefit offered by
columnar file formats is column pruning
so column pruning means that you can
cherry pick uh certain columns uh from
the file and just send those to cluster
now by cherry pick cherry picking
certain columns you send less data to
the cluster which is actually a massive
performance gain so in this little
example here we have our cluster of
three computers
we have our data file that has six
columns
now suppose we're running a query that
only needs three of those columns of
data
we can just send those three columns
over to the cluster
now if you're using a row based file
format like csv that's not possible but
with parquet that's possible
next slide please
another great uh
performance benefit we get from parque
files is row group filtering
now
similar to uh the column pruning
whenever you can send less data to the
cluster you can expect a big performance
again in your query
now parquet files have uh
row group metadata on columns
and certain filtering queries can be
structured so that you're only sending
certain row groups to the cluster rather
than all of them which can be a huge
performance gain i actually
in my talk yesterday i showed a query
that when you use a predicate pushdown
filtering with parquet you get a 25x
performance gain so feel free to watch
that talk if you want to see some more
examples
uh next slide please
okay so now i'm going to pass it over to
rick
he is going to talk about desk at a high
level and then he's going to dive into
those parquet concepts that i just
covered in much more detail and
rick is a parque genius so you're in for
a real treat
thanks for the introduction matt um yeah
so
my name is rick zamora i'm
a
engineer at nvidia and a pretty frequent
contributor to das data frame
um and so yeah since in this workshop
we're really focusing on the use of desk
and part the parquet format for
doing big data processing it makes a lot
of sense for us to first start with you
know an overview of what desk is
and what parque is and how they're
integrated so uh let's get started with
that next slide please
so yeah we'll start with the with the
desk introduction and so what is desk
it's a flexible library for parallel
computing and python with sort of uh
emphasis on flexible and python here
in order to understand what dasc is uh
you know there's a pretty broad task
ecosystem with lots of different
projects that tie into task but for the
purposes of this talk we can understand
task as really being a combination of
three general components a core library
a distributed library and then these
collection apis that users typically use
to interact with or use desks so next
slide
so the first component of dash that
we'll talk about will refer to as the
core library
and you can think of the core library as
being where the implementations are for
single machine
schedule task scheduling engines i think
from here on out i'll probably just
refer to these as the schedulers
but so a single missing machine
scheduler would be you know something
that's going to be able to schedule your
work within a single machine whether you
put in parallel using multiple threads
or multiple processes on that single
machine and so the three schedulers that
are included there are the threaded
scheduler the multi-process scheduler
and a synchronous scheduler which is
really just threaded scheduler but with
one thread so it says you know let's do
everything on one thread
the core library also includes
generally a task graph specification
which is actually pretty simple it's
just a python dictionary of tuples
i'm not going to go into the nitty
gritty details of exactly all the
details of of a task graph and
how we also use things like high level
graphs but what you should understand is
that in this task graph the nodes of the
graph are just going to be some form of
computation some computation function
um and then the the you know the edges
between those nodes and the graph would
just be dependencies of the output
of those tasks all right next slide
okay so in addition to the core engine
of das there's also the distributed
engine i mentioned before that in the
core engine we have the single machine
schedulers that doesn't help a lot when
you want you know to work on many
districts and a cluster with many
distributed machines
and so in order to use distributed
scheduling you actually need a separate
python package called distributed
and
yeah so it's it's really just in
addition so if you want to if you the
distributed package is going to depend
on the core desk engine for most of the
logic but then this allows you to
actually schedule schedule and execute
the test um in a distributed manner
next slide please
and so the last component that i think
is really important are the das
collection apis the big data collection
apis are often referred to as
and so the purpose of these collection
apis is that this is really where most
users are going to interact with das
most users are not going to need to know
how to construct the custom task graph
and execute it on all the workers
they're going to be using something like
desk array or das data frame so that
they can work with an api that looks
similar to something else in the pi data
ecosystem so if you're working with
array data you'll you'll want to work
use desk array because it's going to the
api is going to look a lot like numpy
and if you're using
tabular data you're going to work with
something like that data frame because
the api is going to look just like
pandas
um and you know like i mentioned before
the general purpose here is just make
graph construction and execution pretty
much invisible to the user
next
slide
and so since the collection apis really
are important um um this is just like
another perspective another another way
of understanding i already mentioned
that numpy is is sort of what we are
basing the ask array on so on the left
you see if you would normally be dealing
with a really large array uh maybe
something that doesn't fit in memory or
something that's large enough that you
can get a you know performance boost by
execute by uh doing the computations in
parallel
instead of working with one large numpy
array you can work with a collection of
smaller numpy arrays that would be
arranged
you know on some grid
you know some nd grid
and then for pandas the same thing is
true so instead of working with one
extremely large data frame that maybe
won't fit in in a single machine's
memory or maybe it's large enough that
you can you know get a performance boost
by executing it in parallel you would
just use a das data frame api and the
api would look very similar to
what you would get with panda so like
dd.read.csv looks just like
pd.readcsv the group by
commands look pretty much the same they
look exactly the same all right next
slide
okay so at this point we really
understand the basics of what das is um
so moving from the left we start with
some collection api that the user is
typically going to interact with
something that looks familiar looks like
other pi data
apis like numpy and pandas what's
happening under the hood is that you are
constructing a task graph
that task graph can then just be
executed using some single machine
scheduler or a distributed scheduler
all right next slide
okay now that we have that big picture
in mind i'm going to kind of step back
and go through some details of things
like das data frame and the fast
distributed because these these are
really important for this this general
workshop
so for das dataframe i already mentioned
that when you are working with a really
with really large tabular data das
dataframe allows you to break that that
data set into many different pieces and
what we actually call each of these
pieces in das data frame is a partition
so you may hear me or other people other
speakers refer to partitions
under the you know inside of desk when
you're working with a data frame in desk
you're actually working with a das data
frame collection so that class or that
object that you're working with actually
is a collection of many small pandas
data frames
and then in order to understand
how different operations are going to
modify this data without actually having
to process the data we also carry around
something called metadata you can just
think of metadata as usually being an
empty data frame object something that
kind of provides a schema you know so we
know what the column names are we know
what the data types are and if we do
some sort of operation like adding a
column or doing some kind of
multiplication or group by we know how
that operation is going to modify the
data without actually having to read it
in
um oh next one
and so i already mentioned what is the
purpose of using a data frame uh sorry
of using a collection api like that data
frame it's really so that we are hiding
graph construction from the user
um but allowing them to use you know the
das engine of parallel execution
graph execution and so this is what's
happening if you for a simple example
like read csv
if you have a data set that's large
enough that you um if you call read csv
the the read csv logic will pretty much
take some default chunk size and say oh
this data is big enough i'm going to
break it into two pieces
and so once it has that
that basic information in mind it's
going to build a graph and say okay well
i'm going to read partition 0
up here on the top and then separately
i'm going to read partition 1 in a
separate task down at the bottom and
then if i'm doing a group by aggregation
i might need to do a group by
aggregation on each of these partitions
and then i'm going to do some sort of
tree reduction and and build a graph
that way
so this is all invisible to the user but
this is exactly what's going on under
the head
next slide
and so now we understand
what you know what these collection apis
are actually doing they're building a
task graph so that it can be executed
with one of desk's scheduling engines um
it's also important to understand that
this is all lazy um the tasks the the
graphics the graph construction of these
so what happens when you when you use
something like read csv and then you
calculate unique categories and
everything like that that's relatively
free
so i mean you're doing a little bit of
file system work to figure out where the
files are and how big they are for read
csv that's still you know practically
free
and then um calculating the categories
you're just building a task graph you
can see i show the wall time is just you
know a millisecond here so it's you're
not really doing any work you're not
really processing any data yet what you
need to do with these collection apis is
call something like compute or persist
to actually execute the graph
and so i'm just going to really quickly
here go over the difference between
compute and persist because it can be
pretty important for new users to
understand hey why am i blowing up my
memory on my client process everything's
going crazy well if you call compute
what you're actually doing is you're
materializing an in-memory pandas object
on your client process so if the output
of your um
like if you want to read in a full data
set and you you let's say you just call
read csv and then you compute that ddf
what you're actually doing is moving all
of that data into one pandas data frame
on your room your client process and so
that can be a problem so it's not
recommended if your output of your
compute is something big it's not just
like one number or just like a file name
then you probably don't want to call
compute instead you probably want to
call something like persist what persist
does is it executes your graph but it
preserves your collection so you keep
all your data in distributed memory if
you're using das distributed so that
leads us to the next slide
yeah so like we just went back and
talked a little bit more about das data
frame that's distributed is also very
important for you know scaling to large
systems
when you're using das distributed you
have to kind of have an understanding of
you're breaking the usage of desk into
three parts
first you have you know the client
process the client is where you're
actually using the past data frame api
this is where you're you know you're
going to be running your jupyter
notebook probably here or running your
python script that's using das
and it's tip and you know what you're
doing is you're constructing the graph
on this client process
and then separate from the client
process you have a desk cluster that you
need to deploy i'll go into details
about that after this but what the
cluster is going to include is a
scheduler process and then some um you
know arbitrary number of worker
processes so what happens when you're
using
desk with dash distributed is your
client you're going to construct a graph
you're going to send it to the scheduler
the scheduler is then going to process
that graph and schedule the work on all
these workers
and so you know this is just so you have
the idea of when we talk about the
cluster the scheduler the workers the
client this is what i mean
all right next slide
um yeah so i just mentioned now there
are many ways to actually deploy a
cluster
if you are you know using das just
distributed library you could do this
manually with something like the desk
scheduler or desk worker command line
interface
there are also many convenient cluster
managers out there like if you're
working with kubernetes there's a super
many kubernetes if you're working with
like a on an hpc system where you have
ssc you can use an ssh cluster or it's a
spec cluster
um
also here at the bottom i show a really
convenient api available with desk with
distributed called local cluster so this
is if you kind of want like a quick
start for getting you know for using das
distributed and you just want to work on
a single machine that has multiple cores
you can use
the local cluster to get started
all right next slide
yeah and so the last thing i'm going to
say about like desk at a high level
is that and also that's distributed is
that it offers this nice interactive
dashboard with that's distributed so
when you spin up a cluster
you'll typically create a um a dashboard
process as well which will be sampling
you know metrics of at runtime and so
this is a really beautiful way to you
know build intuition about the
performance that you're getting so
sometimes uh you know people will will
run into issues because they might have
to find some kind of compute uh task
that is running into problems or taking
forever and if you're using uh you know
your interactive dashboard it's really
easy to see oh it's this task right here
that's just taking forever
and so it helps you build intuition
all right next slide
okay so that was our you know brief
introduction to das there's
obviously a lot of things that we could
talk about you know i can give probably
a two hour talk on desk itself but um
for the sake of time we're going to move
over to parquet and how it is
implemented how it can be used with task
next slide
so park a what is it um you know matt
already went into details about park k
so i'm really going to be reiterating a
lot of what he said um but then kind of
talking about the the api used within
the data frame so what is parquet it's a
binary column or storage format it's
designed with things like parallelism
compression and generally performance in
mind
when you imagine a parquet data set you
should just be imagining a collection of
parquet formatted files these files are
you know sometimes they're partitioned
by directories using like high
partitioning but for the sake of
simplicity we can just imagine them as a
collection of files
and
within each of these files you're going
to have a collection of row groups
within each of these row groups you're
going to have a collection of column
chunks
each of these column chunks is where the
data for a specific column will be
stored contiguously
and then within each of these column
chunks it's going to be broken into
pages and
the way to understand parallelism
especially you know if we start with das
if you have different
tasks they're usually going to be
reading a specific group of files or a
specific group of row groups
within each task same goes for mapreduce
the i o engine itself
will usually be do be parallelizing over
multiple column chunks at a time or
maybe multiple pages and then the compo
the encoding and the compression
used for parquet is usually at the page
granularity
one other thing to understand about the
general parquet format is that every
file has this footer metadata down at
the bottom this footer metadata is great
because it tells you exactly where the
offsets for all the column chunks are in
your file
it also tells you
a lot you know optionally but usually
i'll give you statistics about each of
those column chunks which is really
important for things like predicate push
down so you can know like the min and
max value for each column it makes it
much easier to filter
okay next slide
and so a side note on this this footer
metadata although it's not in the
specification to have what's called a
global metadata file usually named or in
dash we assume it's named underscore or
metadata so it's not in the in the park
a specification to have this file but in
das we do uh by default write it out and
we do look for it on the read side um
and all this is is you can imagine if
you take your full data set you take all
the footer metadata from every single
file and you just aggregate it into one
large
global metadata object and write that as
its own standalone file and this is
really convenient you know when you have
cloud file systems uh where it can be
pretty expensive to go and fetch the
floor metadata for every file in the
data set to kind of do the planning
stage of where are all the row groups
where
which columns are we reading and if we
just need to read in one file it can be
much faster there are of course scaling
problems with this that we'll get into
later
but this is just so you understand what
this global metadata file is
on our next slide
okay so as far as das and parque
it the um
so as far as how parquet is available in
das it's really the same way that it's
available in pandas for anybody who's
available
who for anybody who's familiar with
pandas and so
the the api for reading in a park a data
set is just simply read underscore
parquet so if you want to
if you you want to read a parquet data
set using desk you would just import
dash data frame and call it dd.read
parquet and point it to some data source
and it's just the opposite for writing
it at a park a data set so if you have a
das data frame collection like ddf and
you want to write it to a park a data
set you just call to underscore park a
and you point it to an output directory
where you want to write your um where
you want to write your data set out as
it's going to what it's going to do by
default
it's going to write a distinct file for
every one of your partitions in your das
data frame collection
but there are other options
which i'll go to which i'll
mention
i think in two slides all right so next
slide
all right so
basque parque api i already mentioned it
looks very similar to the pandas api for
reading and writing part parquet
datasets
the only way that um and something else
that's actually similar is that it's
backed by different engines just like
the parquet the pandas um
parquet api
allows you to either use the pi aero
engine or a fast park a engine we allow
the same thing in um in das data frame
and so the implementation is what we
would call plugable meaning when you um
when when you use read park a or two
park a you can specify a string to
either pyro or fast par k but you could
also implement your own engine that
inherits from one of these engines or
from the base uh engine and you could
pass that in as well so this is if you
wanted to override you know what the
logic is for reading out a part k
partition or the logic for writing one
out
you can do that if you if you wanted to
uh one thing i'll mention here at the
bottom is i include rapids this is a
case where we actually are using this
feature of
you know the pluggable nature of the
implementation in rapids in basquidf
what we're doing is inheriting from the
dataset engine and then um changing the
the uh the i o backend to be using qdf
instead of something like pyro
and one more note i'll make is that you
know we still have this papyro legacy
option but it will be deprecated in the
near future so just a warning there
all right next slide
okay so the das arcade 2 parquet i'm not
going to go through a whole bunch of
details about what all of these options
are and how they can be used i think
i'll mention the ones that are most
important for scaling
i down at the bottom i've highlighted
this right metadata file option and it's
important i mentioned you know in a lot
of cases you can improve performance by
writing out this global metadata file
because on the read side you then uh can
just look in one place to figure out
where all the partitions are where your
output partitions will come from uh
however this there is non-negligible
overhead of writing this file the way we
can't just append to a single file on
all of our processes instead we do need
one uh one task to sort of aggregate all
the metadata together you know
tie a nice little bow and write it to
disk and that can be a problem if you're
using commodity hardware where you have
you know we don't have enough memory to
do this
um
and there's some overhead in doing this
uh the other thing option i'll mention
as well is there's also things like
partition on which means we can do
directory partitioning if that because i
can improve uh
filtering on the read side but it also
may result in many small files which you
have to be ready to deal with
and then the final thing is the storage
options this is if you're interacting
with cloud storage you might need to
pass things to deal with you know gcs or
with s3 and so this is this is where you
would be adding those options
all right next slide
and on the read parque side um i'm also
not going to go into all of these
details but i will you know just mention
uh as matt mentioned before
you can you know cherry pick which
columns you actually want to read so
since we are using call since the
parquet format uh separates the column
chunks we can specify which columns we
want to read and we can improve i o
performance you know considerably and
the same goes for filters since we have
statistics about each of these column
chunks we can skip over the ones that do
not meet certain filters like if you
only want some you know time stamps that
are beyond some date you would
definitely want to specify that here
because you can end up you know skipping
over most of the data
and then the other thing is this split
row groups i i you know there are ways
to control the
data frame partitioning so you might
want to have one partition for every row
group or you might want to have one
partition for you know a whole group of
row groups and this is how you do it
all right next slide
okay yeah so
but that that gives us our high level
overview of parquet and das i didn't
want to go into too much detail but i'm
happy to follow up you know if there are
questions and i'm happy to answer any
questions about how parquet is
implemented in desk and what people
should use but from here we'll move on
to problems at scale with james
awesome thanks rick uh hi everyone i'm
i'm james i'm uh like many other people
on the call a desk maintainer and i work
at coil as well
um so yeah i want to sort of
start to talk about some of the issues
that we run in whenever you take these
you know sort of parquet workloads and
scale them up to very large data sets on
very large clusters i i do want to just
kind of know to the top
that um
[Music]
how das exists today um it works very
well for etl workloads and really a lot
of commonly used scales so for instance
if we go to the next slide actually
um
here's sort of a motivating example um
this example what we do there's sort of
three steps um
so
that are kind of representative of many
workloads i have an actual example
workload on the right hand side some
real code
so the the first step is we read in our
data set so um like rick just talked
about we can use desk read parquet
functionality to
read in some large data set on s3 using
for instance the the pi aero uh uh
parquet engine we also use fast per k
um so that's sort of the the data ax the
initial data access step we then
followed up by doing some kind of
processing on the data frame um in this
example i'm constructing a new column
which is this is kind of a contrived
example but a new column which is some
function of the you know of other
columns in the data set to create some
new um derived
new derived columns for the ad set um
i've been
after
processing this data set take the data
set and use uh desk's two parquet
functionality to write out this new
processed version of the data set to
some s3 bucket so
this is a
typically what we see we see some some
kind of
you know i o
process uh i o to to write back out
results to
somewhere
we see this type of workload in many
different applications you can imagine
swapping out the process data step
that's here right now the supply to be
you know apply some machine learning
model to your data set to make some
predictions that you then save you know
those predictions to do another parking
data set
these types of workloads um work very
well with basc as it is um you know at
that gigabyte scale
uh tens of gigabytes hundred gigabytes
terabyte scale once you start pushing
things to you know thousands and
thousands of workers and maybe tens and
hundreds of terabytes then you'll notice
uh there are some things to start to
break down which i'll highlight in the
next few slides this is really just a a
way to tee up um martin in the next
section to talk about some of the
improvements uh recent improvements in
desk where we
have
gone through sort of resolving some of
these these issues and been in the last
section we'll talk about some of the
more systemic
issues we'll talk about some longer term
visions for for solving those issues as
well
uh next slide
yeah so uh one issue that we that that
folks run into specifically when using
parquet and ask whenever data frames
have you know many many partitions so we
have tons of you know pandas data frames
that comprise our gas data frame this
consolidated metadata file that rick was
talking about the store is sort of the
metadata for all the individual
partitions can become very large
this actually becomes you know and when
i say very large i mean can be order
gigabytes which can be can be
unfortunate when you're
reading and writing using part k i'm
linking there to a couple of github
issues so you can see real world
examples where this type of issue has
has cropped up
i should say that today it's possible to
not write that consolidated metadata
file out that's one sort of not solution
but workaround is hey i'm actually not
going to write out this consolidated
metadata file
for my super large data sets uh the
issue is that that can make subsequent
reads slow um so you know whenever you
there's there's a reason this metadata
file exists to begin with um otherwise
we'd have to go through and sort of
serially process you know read in every
partition uh in our in our data set uh
you know load in it's it's that and sort
of construct the equivalent of this
metadata file on the fly and that itself
can be very slow when you have these
large data sets with many partitions um
and it's interesting you'll run into
lots of uh rather like we we were
uh we ran into issues with this large
metadata file in lots of different spots
in the in the software stack um for
instance there was some there was a pi
arrow issue um you know we were talking
about using the pyro um uh
parquet uh engine inside desk uh with
with uh there was some issue with the
actual uh loading in parquet of these
large metadata files there was some
issue with um uh thrift this has since
been resolved um so sort of giving you a
sneak peek for uh the improvement
section uh but yeah issues like this
have cropped up and we're sort of going
through and taking care of them as we
can
uh next slide please
when scaling up your workloads there's
lots of um
this doesn't always mean scaling to the
cloud but you know today it actually
largely does me moving to the cloud
although you may have access to a you
know giant
giant machine that you can just have a
local cluster on um and not have to go
to cloud or maybe you have access to
some hpc system if you have a slurm job
queueing system or something along those
lines
in which case you don't have to move to
the cloud to scale to these large
workloads but for many people uh it does
mean scaling of the clouds there's
actually several uh sort of
considerations when scaling to the cloud
that you have to keep in mind one is the
environment of the workers um so uh this
means that so that's what it'll actually
do so whenever rick was talking about
sort of constructing the graph that will
happen wherever you are running gas code
so that may be in your python
script or in your jupiter notebook
you're actually going to construct the
graph there and ask will take all of the
things you want it to do so like you
know it'll take the read parquet calls
it'll take the numpy sum call actually
ship those off to the workers that means
that your workers have to have a
consistent environment with wherever you
may be running your python code so you
need to make sure you have for instance
pi arrow installed on the workers in the
same version of pyro that you have
installed locally on say your laptop
where you're where you have your das
client session
so sort of one consideration that comes
whenever you're going scaling from a
single machine to multiple machines you
also have to worry about securing the
cluster and i i guess really what i mean
by that is is a couple of points um
securing the cluster in the sense of
like provisioning nodes so you have to
understand how to spin up say
uh ec ec2 instance on aws if that's sort
of the cloud bar you're using or the
equivalent in gcp or azure you have to
worry about actually spinning up those
those um
those nodes as well as making sure
they're all connected in the same
network and have access to one another
another thing is you have to make sure
that things are properly secured in a
like security uh sense i'm using the
same word several times but uh you have
to make sure that for instance you you
might want to use encryption whenever
you're communicating messages from from
one node to another so making sure you
have the appropriate you know tls
certificates set up for desk to support
that
whenever you move from one machine to
another machine you also have to worry
about um
sort of the permissions model and
credentials for various data access
so you may have your for instance local
laptop configured to
um you know you have your aws config
file set up where you can access f3
buckets um locally from your machine um
but you you need to make sure that the
the workers you're using have the same
access to access you know s3 or google
or azure blob storage or whatever data
store you may be using
luckily um fs spec which i linked to the
documentation there and has been talked
about already in the talk which martin
maintains actually
um along with others uh it bridges the
gap between a lot of these different
storage backends so fs spec is sort of
martin can elaborate more on it but my
definition of it would be a sort of
uniform api for file store storage
access so it doesn't matter whether or
not you're using a
local file system
or
accessing files on github or accessing
files in s3 or google or azure or files
in dropbox they all have a sort of
uniform
interface for doing operations like
opening files reading files writing
files listing files uh things along
those lines and so fspec has done a
really great job of sort of unifying uh
data access
that said there are still differences
between the various storage back-ends
which sort of the differences between
these become important um at scale
uh next slide
so once you've sort of taken all these
things into consideration um you know
you have your cluster provisioned it's
using encryption between all the
different various nodes you've you know
set up credentials so that uh you can
access all of your data gcp on all of
your workers there's still other things
that you'll other issues will run into
when when doing these large etl modes
one is
file system caching so
there is this desire in in cloud storage
to to cache um results that's to avoid
sort of repeating expensive operations
this is great from a performance
perspective but from a consistency
perspective can be less than ideal i'm
linking there to an issue where there
was some
interesting errors arising because of
these inconsistencies due to file system
caching
another
type or class of of issue that you'll
run into is uh limits so linking it to
another issue where um you'll you'll
start to hit things like s3 limits in
particular if you have you know some
uh
huge you know 10 000 uh worker cluster
um doing
s3 things hitting s3 endpoints you'll
see that you know you'll have that what
that means is you have like 10 000
workers concurrently hitting s3 and
maybe hitting in multiple threads at the
same time um so you you can pretty
easily hit uh an s3 or cloud
cloud
throttling limits
there are ways around this with retries
but this is something that that's
supposed to run into another is partial
rights which ben will talk about later
um due to sort of in femoral workers
maybe you're using spot instances in
your cluster or maybe your auto scale
and so you have workers coming and going
throughout your throughout your
computation
um anyways these are sort of the the
types of problems that that folks run
into i've linked to a few relevant
issues for real-world examples and now
next slide i'll turn it over to martin
to talk about some of the recent
ecosystem improvements um
to help resolve some of these issues
take it away martin
hi thank you um
my brief introduction i i work at
anaconda i've had this job for six years
working mainly on open source i'm the
principal author of fast park a and f
specs you just heard
so
what has happened in the dark ecosystem
to try and make
some of the problems you just heard
about go away or at least not be quite
so important
so next slide please
i should say these first couple of
things the developments within dusk
itself was mainly done by rick um but
there were a few more people including
myself who are involved in this but yeah
rick gets the majority of the credit
here
um one thing that you just heard about
is what if your parquet descent
consists of very very many pieces those
pieces usually we think of many row
groups and many files
this creates a very large desk graph and
that puts strain principally on your
scheduler so one thing you might want to
do is to have each of your tasks read
several parts of your overall data set
and this we call the
the
aggregation
and there are a couple of things that
that you can do to
grab these into tasks and having done
that and what first you need to analyze
your data set to know what the pieces
are but once you form your task graph
the end result can be that your test
graph is much smaller than it would have
been otherwise and that means that the
scheduler doesn't work as hard
it doesn't need to take up as much
memory for the graph itself
at the cost of obviously each of your
partitions is going to take up more
memory
so it's a trade-off and many of these
things are trade-offs because when you
reach the real big
size limits then you have to think a
little bit more carefully about the
processing that you're having to do
there's some code example here that i we
won't go over now but we can talk about
it later
next slide please
um we talked about this
metadata file a bit
so um this is something that
is uh since quite a i think two or three
years maybe more in spark this is no
longer the default to write this and
um so we already were facing the case
that the metadata file might not be
present so we were able to cope with
that but
even if it is present you might choose
not to read it and the reason is even
though it would be a single read to get
all of your metadata across the whole of
your data set
it nevertheless can be quite big and
this processing of the metadata file
itself was done in the client so it's a
serial process that might use lots of
memory
if it isn't there then in order to
process all of your data
you need to be able to find out the
metadata of at least each piece
in the workers so you end up using more
cpu overall but you can spread that cpu
use over your workers
so ignoring the metadata file is now an
option
and you may choose to use it
and it might bring you great
improvements in the case that your
metadata file is very big
however it doesn't always help you so
it's another trade-off that you need to
think about
moving on
so uh as a kind of summary those are
two detail slides that we can come back
to if there are questions but there are
some other improvements that have
happened specifically within desk so the
first one is the counterpart to what i
just said you might choose not to read a
metadata file in some cases well in that
case maybe for that particular data set
there's actually no point to write the
metadata and that will save you time
when you do the writing because you
don't need to have the extra task that
does this metadata right and that task
can actually be very heavy too because
it needs to wait on all of the metadata
pieces from all of the previous tasks
and merge them into a single thing
and that single thing can then take up a
lot of memory and it might fail which
will leave you in a bad position so now
you have the choice not to do that
uh the aggregation i already mentioned
but um it's it's an
interesting option and actually you can
aggregate at various levels so
please read the documentation carefully
because it it takes a little bit of
getting your head around how that works
and
again on the metadata now that we have
the option not to use a metadata file
you can do the processing of the
metadata so that you can set up your
task graph also on the workers that's a
relatively new feature
and it's a
again an interesting thing that you are
trading off uh efficiency
for
speed across the network
to get your all of your
workers to do a little bit of processing
for you so it's a sort of dusky thing to
do but
having
desk do work so that you can set up your
data frame in the first place was
something that tucker's a bit of
convincing that this was a good idea
uh final couple of points here uh
spark conformers we did put some work in
making some of the quicks that were a
little bit different between how dasc
operated and how spark operated go away
specifically by
comparing workloads and specific data
sets across spark and desk so that is
ongoing we haven't covered everything
but we've definitely covered at least a
couple of cases
and finally um i'll mention this again
in a moment pyro itself has changed
quite a lot over the last couple of
years particularly they've brought in a
new api for
data io called dataset and so
within the arrow arm of the code in desk
you can now access either the old arrow
api or the new one and they both come
with
similar set of options but not
everything is identical so it's worth
understanding that there is this
difference the new api is the only one
that will
be
um supported eventually i'm not sure
when that when the old legacy api will
be dropped but at some point it will
moving on
so those are things that happen
specifically within basque itself but
other things have happened in the
ecosystem which is what i'm mainly
supposed to be talking about but this
has been quite covered in other places
so there's a link here to
my blog about specifically fastpake and
i'm happy to go over the details of what
all of these things mean but
there's quite a lot of detail so i will
only go into it if people are interested
but suffice to say there were a lot of
changes and this was a
pretty major push of mine over the
months leading up to august when it was
finally released
and a lot of things happen
um we reduced the dependencies of
fastback so that importing it is faster
and a minimal environment it takes to
install it is much smaller
we also brought in a load of new
features including the
pake v2
data
pages which come with some performance
improvements new types
optional filtering new encodings and
also a real drive to get performance
better at least under read side and
there are some benchmarks that are shown
in there again in this blog and then the
final one this has not been merged or
released but i am very happy that it
works just a little scared to put it out
into the while is to
rewrite thrift in my own custom psyphon
code so that we don't depend on thrift
anymore and it's actually much faster
it's not as
um
conformant let's say it's not the
industry standard it's my own code so
that's the reason that i've held off and
it would also require some changes
within desk and other dependent projects
to use it
so it will take a bit of
effort and coordination to bring that
about
next slide
uh similarly and actually partly driven
by the same process that i was trying to
optimize fast parka it turns out that
the i o layer has a lot of optimization
possibilities
such as even on a local file system a
surprising amount of time is spent
managing
strings so that you can get past right
and checking for each of those strings
does the file exist how big is the file
and opening the file and if you have a
file
a data set made up of thousands of files
these things add up so uh some smarts
about how you do this
have really
resulted in pretty substantial speedups
in some very specific workloads so
this is what happens when you when you
do uh
benchmark driven
development as ben alluded to at the
start you can improve specific things
and not necessarily make a difference to
the typical workflow so um all of these
things need to be done with a
mind to am i actually making things
worse for anybody else
and i think on the whole effort spec is
improved in a way that matters to
parquet so i mentioned that one also in
s3 and some of the other remote file
systems try to get rid of redundant
calls these are typically in a file info
and file listing layer not the actual
access of files
the third one is something that we're
still actually actively working on
because it's hard to get right um you
you heard that we need to do retry
sometimes because the
cloud systems will only take so many
requests per second but at what level to
do these retries and exactly what
pattern of retries you want to do is
complicated if you allow for lots of
retries then something that genuinely
fails for some reason might take a very
long time to tell you that it's failed
on the other hand as you increase the
number of requests
a certain fraction of them will fail so
you need more retries the bigger your
workload the more retries you will need
you also need to
retry specific things like if the
request comes back actually saying for
example one of the messages you may get
is
your quota of request for this second
has been exceeded please try again later
you need to recognize that and you need
to wait an appropriate amount of time
before trying again other things like
server cannot be found are re-tried on a
completely different level so there are
many things that interact here and it's
quite difficult to get around
and this is why this is still a work in
progress
concurrent fetching of data from remote
has been in fspec for a while now for s3
gcsfs and azure and http
actually making use of those is a work
in progress on the parquet side
fspec supports a bunch of back-ends and
there are more coming so uh that's just
interesting read um the core ones that
we're talking about here have been
around for a while though
and all of these different projects the
fspec is like the core but there are
many packages now that depend on it and
we are reorganizing ourselves to be able
to give users
more clear channels for feedback and
conversation
so there is an fspec.org on github that
already exists but only contains just
the one package for the moment well
where we aim to do this
uh one particularly interesting thing
that i include this only partly because
i'm going to be talking about it later
today in the talk quality neither
is the idea of kachong which is a
package to make virtual
file systems out of paths that exist in
different places this is interesting for
parquet because parquet has a
hierarchical directory oriented dataset
model so you can construct a parquet
data set of a virtual file system where
you don't need to
copy the files themselves into a
particular directory system in order to
make them appear as if they have
particular special place within the
directory hierarchy now that might have
seemed greek to you the thing that i
just said but the
point of it is that you can
use the partitioning logic that parquet
has
in order to
make a virtual data set an aggregate
data set over many other data sets
we're going to produce some examples of
this in action so that you can actually
see how it works so we haven't done that
yet so please look out for that in the
future
and then finally i i think this is
specifically mentioned in the uh
coming soon
is that you can since parque is special
and we know where within a parquet file
all of the byte blocks that we need are
we can prefetch them using
fspec efficiently and be able to get a
faster read speed from that
again this is coming up so uh
i i refer you to that
next slide
now i don't have many specifics on arrow
itself because i'm not the expert on
that but arrow has been in constant
rapid development over the last well
actually
for quite a long time but specifically
the parquet part the dataset
api has been
improving a lot and a lot of that
improvement has been the ability for
das in particular to be able to get
access to the data
metadata pieces that it needs to be able
to
implement the improvements that we've
already talked about so arrow have been
very
responsive to our request to be able to
surface that metadata
and largely we've been busy in
implementing those
improvements on the basis of what has
been available from arrows so we've had
a quite a lot back and forth between the
two groups to get that right and uh
yeah it's a it's largely been
uh
try to keep up with the rapid pace of
what arrow is doing
uh how much of that has resulted in
specific improvements in performance i
don't really know but perhaps we can
talk about that afterwards
and i think that's it from me
so uh handing over to ben
again um
before before i
i uh keep going i wanted to
mention why why we focused on the in
this talk on s3 and parquet so we we
actually in the last especially in the
last few months but definitely over the
last year we've had a lot of um the
community
a lot of customers reach out and say we
think that this could be done better in
in the desk ecosystem
many of the workloads from from the
community and customers were
were
the i o limited that they had data on s3
or gcsf gcsfs or some other cloud
storage thing and they also all their
data was in
parquet so it's obvious for us to focus
on those things however many of these
ideas also translate as i said to other
cloud storage things but also to other
binary formats like orc or
avro
and i wanted to also take a moment and
reflect on like how we got here not just
as like a pi data community but like as
a data engineering community like the
world at large
maybe we got here i don't i don't know
for sure but it seemed like you know the
whole world was on databases probably
long before any of us were born
they've been around for a long time and
um maybe maybe some of us who are the
older folks that are around um
and databases were great um but we
needed to do we needed like as um as
individuals or as workflows develop we
needed to do a lot more with
the data that was kind of housed in a
singular in a singular database they
either we needed more might mean we had
scaling problems more might mean we
needed to run like non-linear functions
or we needed like more customized
user-defined functions to be executed on
rows just needed databases to flex in
ways that they hadn't really been
designed to
and as the cloud kind of got going it
became
such a wonderful place to to get
globally available data you didn't spin
up i like eventually people maybe stop
spinning up just a singular mysql
database
because s3 offered globally accessible
data that was a that was a huge
improvement
and with all these improvements came
other pain points
so i'm going to maybe talk briefly about
what
what some of those pain points are
because we needed to
typically these pain points are around
custom solutions that we don't have
best practices as we make these lateral
moves
of getting like the flexibility that we
want
in in python and bringing them into
databases or as the lateral moves look
like from moving away from databases to
these new
data storage formats bringing in
security or bringing in
a high availability we hit other kinds
of problems
so
so we have these words we've said
database i'm about to say the word data
lake maybe the word data warehouse i'm
not really clear on these definitions
but maybe a data lake is like i'm just
storing
all of my data in s3 and that was as i
was just saying like that was really
great i get globally accessible data
but
we have now a bunch of problems with
that or we have all these custom
solutions on top of that because we want
to build things that look like maybe as
data comes in we leverage other tooling
in aws to have some event driven system
so a new file comes into s3 and now we
want to as soon as new data is there we
want to have
sqs or some q a rabbitmq or some other
queuing system that's monitoring the
buckets and saying
as soon as the data comes in process it
in this other way and shove it into my
sql database for some other kinds of
post-processing that i want to do on it
i need to build
um
some other customizations as data as raw
data comes into some global storage
system
that
as the first bullet point says that link
isn't readable while while the right is
happening
um
so in my in my mind like the the
canonical example is some windowing
operation some time series thing i'm
pulling in data from
an iot device or there's some financial
transaction or something that's
happening on
every minute or every hour or every day
it's very quickly it's very easy to
quickly achieve the kinds of problems
that used to just be reserved for google
or twitter or even like the large hadron
collider we can hit these terabyte
problems or even petabyte problems much
sooner so we have to
scale this solution that we currently
have
so we need to be able to do things like
listing lots of files it's a very common
we need to be able to handle
transactions where the cluster might die
it's really easy to
to test the limits of aws and see when a
compute node might might die or some
worker might die
we need to handle
bleeding a few rows from data we need to
update things
and as we update larger data sets we
want to find other optimizations like
combining
combining small files so for example if
you're writing things every minute or
every hour we might want to compact all
that to a day's worth of work
these are the things that used to be
canonical inside of databases that we
could run through these operations in a
way that didn't
destroy the database or destroy like the
execution of workloads that were going
on concurrently
so to get into a little bit of more
finer points of
um
we were just saying
um
we saw lots of examples like james
showed this example of we're going to
read some data then we're going to do
some analysis and then we're going to
write out
and that's great if it's just you
but that's not going to work if you have
10 users where
we or 10 10 workflows that need to run
simultaneously where we read in some
data
and then
uh or sorry we are trying to write some
data as we're trying to to read from it
um this might look
more like transactions rather than batch
processing
um as i said before when we get to lots
and lots of data if you ever try to list
all the files in an s3 bucket where
there's 100 000 files or more you'll
you'll feel that you'll
see it happening where you're just
twiddling your thumbs for 10 seconds
we want to we want to resolve these
kinds of problems as well
by we i don't mean just ask i mean the
larger broader data engineering
community and this isn't just true
this isn't a problem that's inherent to
death this is a problem that's inherent
to
how
the data world has shifted into these
large cloud storage systems
um when we have this problem of
compacting many small files so for folks
here that have leveraged um
uh directory partition data or high
partition data you might want to you'll
end up with many small files and
optimization here is compacting them
into
a larger
a larger chunk
again these are things kind of outside
the desk world but optimizations that
the larger engineering machine within
your organization is going to look for
and a terrible terrible problem to run
into is what happens where if you are
just leveraging s3 in part k
or any binary format or csvs is what
happens if you're writing
writing out your job or the job is
finished now you're at the last step of
writing something happens and it does if
you run out of memory
uh desk can help resolve those things
but you know a strain neutrino hits the
it's a
uh an ec2 node and now you have
partially written files
you now have a
choice here maybe there's lots of ways
to resolve this problem you can re run
the entire job which maybe that's not um
maybe that's not too painful or maybe
that's extremely painful depending on
the kind of job it was or you have to go
through and manually find which files
were corrupted
i believe that powers has had the
experience of probably trying to do all
those and many more
um
so perhaps people here when we open it
up for discussion can speak to these
kinds of problems as well
and then now with gdpr compliance right
the right to be forgotten
if all of if you've built a service or
you've built something that that
leverages public data
um
and it's all in s3 you don't have some
some higher level thing or even actually
if you have both
gdpr mandates that you go and delete
that row
so how how do we build a system that can
now efficiently handle this
again using it's not it's not a desk
problem using just s3
and just part k is not enough anymore to
handle these these problems as we're as
we're scaling
so in comes um these three potential
solutions that we've seen in the in the
marketplace
um these are
i believe all apache projects
maybe delta lake is not
um
and these are put up by larger companies
netflix is working on them uh netflix
and google maybe are working on iceberg
delta lake is
being developed by spark
i'm not sure who the major backers are
of apache hoodoo but
these um
oh apache drew it as well thanks
people are
people uh larger companies are looking
at the kinds of problems that are that
um manifest with just these s3 parquet
plus a bunch of customizations
and all these requirements from
from
legal entities like the european union
so
uh to focus on one of them but i think
that these are broadly true across um
across all three
um
is that we can solve a lot of a lot of
problems by just adding a transaction
log maybe on top of this this um on top
of s3 or
so
so delta lake
has this transaction log which is really
nice it lets us do time travel which is
always really fun to say even though
it's not as exciting as actual
time travel but we can go back and see a
history of the database and that's
really critical like as you if you have
some partial rights you can resolve this
thing by going back in time and looking
at what happened
when we added files one and two or we
deleted files three and four
this is again this lateral move that
we've made from from regular databases
we've been able to roll back things
in database land for quite some time as
we went to s3 we needed those same kinds
of solutions available to us
um
yeah this is like kind of the the huge
improvement that we've made on top of it
but there's um there's a ton in in the
in the data lake space i'm sorry that
they've also kind of made globbing and
filed this thing easier made security a
lot easier they've resolved a lot of
problems that
um that we see when you just have
the hive metastore on s3 um
which yeah um maybe i'll i'll leave it
there and we can talk more about this
in the discussion time
so desk wants to so there's desk wants
to play in that space we need better
data lake integrations
there's already a
pr up for
for delta lake and we're talking
regularly with the apache iceberg
community
we heard a lot about
about um metadata improvements that
we're pushing into
to parquet or into um
starting to fast parquet and to the the
arrow readers inside of desk there's
other file formats that we haven't
talked about um
we briefly briefly mentioned orc
and avro but
those while those things are tabular
there's other binary formats that are
popular in the hpc or the academic or nd
nd array space so
mainly czar here we could apply these
same kinds of ideas to the metadata
handling within tsar or maybe work more
with that community and think about ways
that we can leverage
um
other kinds of metadata improvements to
make fancy selection and indexing kind
of uh
faster or
or possible or easier to to spell
for us as developers and ultimately for
the end users
we've also been
we lightly touched on predicate push
down by that i mean
um
if we are trying to do
[Music]
a join on two dash data frames across a
couple columns and at the end of this
we're only going to look at two columns
we can push that predicate that
selection of the kinds of columns that
we need at the end instead to the very
beginning so if if we're reading if the
the user naively
read in all of the columns at once from
a large table but at the end of the
workflow we only needed one or two we
can push that all the way we das can
maybe develop some mechanism to say
actually at the beginning only read in
the first two don't do what the user did
and again sql query like database
engines have been able to do these kinds
of operations um and we're adding them
to desk
yeah
um
so there's a ton of really great
improvements inside of desk it's really
great for for etl the work is ongoing
we're deeply engaged in trying to
improve things here especially in the
cloud space and thinking about the
future and integrating with these um
other other data
lake engines
and we have a new discourse room and i'd
encourage everybody here to come to
discourse for a
lengthier
and more detailed and very importantly
searchable chat
um
so with that i'd like to thank all of
our um speakers martin
matt rick and james and and open it up
for for a broader broader discussion
and we have plenty of time so
please
don't be shy
uh you can type in the chat and we can
pick those up or um
do
do participants have the ability to
unmute themselves
they should have yet
maybe we should continue the
conversation that i'm seeing in the chat
on
the the database versus
data lake problem as it does to gas it
sounds like
as we scale up how we use das we're
discovering we need all the
functionality
that we get with a traditional database
management system
plus all the things that it can do now
do we need to eventually implement this
kind of stuff i was looking at the
transaction logs that you were talking
about that there
eventually when we do it all
right martin if you uh i have an opinion
here but maybe you want to go first yeah
yeah well um
the answer is sort of yes and no
there is
an an existing long
thread or several threads about the
handoff between sql and
dusk and how much of your work can you
push into the sql layer
obviously
you need to understand your database and
have it optimized and all the rest of it
have it scalable for that to work
and it's definitely far from perfect how
desk interacts with it but it's
workable so um
it solves some workflow there's also the
desk sql and blazing sql projects that
implement sql like
functionality on dask
but
a dusk is not built specifically for
that task so
i doubt that it will ever be as well
optimized to
very strictly sql-like workflows your
your typical
join aggregate type of thing
if you have your data in a database it's
going to do that better because it has
lookup trees and all the rest of it to
be able to do a really efficient job and
we can try to make desk better be able
to do those things but probably
reinventing everything in desk is not on
the table i don't think
it has been talked about and in
particular i think blazing sql has gone
a long way to do the query optimization
part of that
i i don't know
like dust sequel
also has done a lot i don't know how far
down the road it's gone so far
um
but dusk's power
isn't
that it would be it's a it's a nice to
have to use the same technology for all
the parts of your workflows and you
don't need to worry about
deploying all the different pieces
but
the more general
that you make your tool the less well it
will be optimized for any particular
part of it right
so
i i would hope that we don't do it i
think that's that's my
my end opinion on that
go ahead
ben uh i would add not just that
well for many things desk is not the
delta lake is the tool that's written by
the by um
by data bricks there's a reason that it
is separate from spark and that they
work on tight integration i think
similarly
desk is a really great tool and the end
will have really great integrations
between lots of other great database or
data warehousing solutions it's not i
don't think that desk will want to eat
the world and own all of those things
you'll you'll want to have other
projects that
like the rest i mean
arguably this is because
in my opinion like the pi data community
has figured out how to interoperate so
well together that that's where the
power from these tools come from and
similarly desk will interoperate with
kind of tooling outside of it i think
we're also not best positioned to solve
those particular problems and that
engineers at netflix that regularly hit
those problems are open sourcing their
solutions for all of us to use
yeah i think just to jump in here too
sorry go ahead let me know you're done
all done
i think yeah we can also kind of get the
best of both worlds with in some regards
as well because of like query push down
stuff so i think like for example with
the
snowflake connector from what i
understand
we can do like a huge join on the
snowflake side you know because huge
joins joining two two tables this two
huge tables was tough in the cluster
environment so we could do the two the
huge join on the snowflake side
and then use parallel i o to send those
results to the desk cluster and then do
our machine learning models on the dash
cluster so i think that
my my vision of the future is kind of
like
the best of both worlds for some of
these things
based on where where the computation
should take place
there is the a question in the chat just
a general comment about where spark is
versus desk that's something that comes
up a lot and
we can also talk about ray maybe if
people are interested about that but uh
matt since you you specifically touched
the
spark versus dusk do you have anything
to say in this
specifically parquet at scale context
uh yeah sure yeah i think for most um
workflows desk and spark are both great
options
for
etl type stuff
i think a lot of times
python people prefer
desk
and don't like doing jvm type stuff so
my feeling is that
they're both great
obviously
spark is a little different because it
has the query optimizer so there's some
nice uh optimizations that spark has
that desk doesn't quite have but what i
understand
where
the query optimization stuff is
underway and starting to get work on it
in the desk world
and james knows more about that than
that
we do specifically have a documentation
comparing
usage of spark and usage of desk
doesn't go into
low level details
yeah to give everybody some higher level
context the reason i switched to the
desk world is
you can kind of it's a lot easier to
build customized stuff in the desk world
compared to the spark world uh you can
build customized stuff in the spark
world if you're
willing to write
catalyst expressions but that's some
that's really crazy and hard and i was
starting to mess around with java
bytecode and i was like i don't want to
do this anymore
while we have a little bit of silence i
can comment very briefly about ray since
i did just mention it
um as far as i can tell
it may
get to
a place where rey also performs
general purpose computing workloads like
we're talking about here etl type stuff
and
uh
more flexible things and i think it
probably already can it just doesn't
seem to be the typical use case for ray
at the moment uh for those that don't
know rey is a as another
parallelism system for python
and it mainly seems to be directed
very specifically by design at machine
learning so that's the
goal that ray has whereas
dusk again interfaces with machine
learning but it isn't specifically built
for that
it's a question about x-ray which is uh
something i'm also
involved in um
x-ray has an optional dependency on
desks so you can choose to open your
data sets
backed by desk which means if you have a
distributed cluster or a large machine
then you can get nice parallelism and
out of core computation
um as far as i remember the only the way
to trigger it
is when you do x-ray open data set if
you include chunks equals magic keyword
parameter then you will get a desk
backed
data set instead of uh it's still lazy
the non-desk version is still lazy you
don't get the data for a particular
array until you access it but it will
get all of the data in one go which
might not fit into your memory
there are quite a lot of examples of
using x-ray with desk with
videos of the dashboard and all that
kind of thing so you can check those out
there's a question about
parquet sizing
rick since you've explored both gpu and
cpu things do you have any
yeah sure um and yeah and as you imagine
ben as you mentioned um yeah so i work a
lot with um i'm on the rapids team and
so i'd spend a lot of time with das
kudia
i think people who are
reading in data sets using qdf as the i
o engine and
so for those cases we usually want to
have you know
either either the user will specifically
design their data set to have something
like one to four gigabyte
files so that each file will become a
partition when you read it in
um or we'll just say yeah write really
large parquet files so that you can sort
of scale that and you can say oh i want
to have 10 row groups per partition or i
want to have 100 row groups per
partition and just have like these giant
you know 10 plus gigabyte parquet files
and that seems to work fine but
something to keep in mind
is that the default setting for read
parquet
is that you will get one partition per
row group
and
sometimes that's a good thing and
sometimes that's really small
sometimes
you know if if you just write out one
file
with one row group which i think is
maybe the default for things like uh pi
arrow this can not you know maybe you
can't if you just write out one large 10
gigabyte file that could be too big for
processing things on gpus
you might run out of gpu memory um so to
go back
picking
the size of the file
to um
you know it depends a lot on the
hardware it depends a lot on cpu or
whether you're using a gpu and so i
think we we usually see
files in you know under a gigabyte just
just in case um but you know
i i guess maybe others who because most
of the time i spent benchmarking is
using gpus lately so i don't have the
best recommendations for what's the
fastest thing in cpu i think martin
might have the best idea there
but i would see i would generally see
files that are under a gigabyte for
for cpu usage is that right martin
i think it's worth saying that whatever
your workflow is you
you're best off trying to uh
evaluate and benchmark and otherwise
analyze some subset before you get going
on all of it
uh we used to always recommend each
partition be larger than 100 megabytes
that's still in the documentation
somewhere i think
and that was largely born out of a
question of latency when talking to io
layers
that might not be the thing that your
bottlenecked on
especially if you're using some of these
tricks to aggregate multiple row groups
into a single task which is relatively
new
so uh
there are a few things to consider
there's the graph size which will give
us the number of partitions in your data
set
there is the discovery phase which will
go as the number of
files because you need to read the
footer of all of those files
there's the memory footprint of each of
your tasks which you can only
really know by trying out a task on one
of your partitions and profiling the
memory use while that's happening
it's
hard to know how much space a particular
partition of
parquet data will actually need in
memory because uh depends on a whole
load of factors
so you should have an idea of what that
is and
therefore how many partitions you can
fit in memory at a time before
exhausting your worker's memory keeping
in mind that whatever processing you're
doing to that data will probably make
some temporary objects while it's
happening
so you should try it
you should benchmark it and then you
know double it or something uh build a
safety margin to make sure that your
workers don't die at the critical phase
80 through your workflow
on actual recommendation well the
trouble with desk this is kind of the
killer feature and also the problem is
that dusk works well on a
on a laptop on a sort of eight gigabyte
memory laptop with four cores it works
well there and it also works well on on
a single monster machine with i don't
know 500 gigabytes of ram or whatever
you can get these days and it also works
well on
a kubernetes cluster of
a thousand containers or whatever it may
be
and probably if you're in a in a space
to make choices the choices that you
would make to get the best performance
will not be the same for each of those
three cases
so
uh yeah measurement i think is key
i didn't give a number
i think less than a gigabyte is probably
where i would sit
[Music]
i think that number might also change as
you
like depending on
other contexts like if you have local
storage or as you were just saying if
you're on s3
like
pulling if you have
many many small files in s3 that might
be really advantageous to
um to
pulling data from on
many workers
um
what i've i've also found is that being
able to experiment like you're saying
martin is really useful
um
many engineers depend in organizations
don't
will not spend that time experimenting
and will like bash their head against
trying to solve this problem at another
end point or we'll just
um
we'll just not experiment at all or it's
too hard to shift away from
picking maybe maybe the question is if
you were to pick a general size forever
and you weren't allowed to move away
from it what would it be
that at organizations it might just be
we just have two gigabyte partitions
that's it it's too hard to move all of
the data to something else
yeah what i would say moving forward is
that it has become less important to
choose a good file size as long as you
have row groups that are a reasonable
size so in the past people were coming
to us running on things where they just
had one giant row group per file which
is what i was saying before where
sometimes you just could not read in
that data set if you're using something
like a gpu or you just have don't have
enough memory to read it in
and because that's the granularity at
which you can create partitions is at
least one row group or a combination or
a collection of row groups right and so
if as long as you have a small enough
row group that you can you know choose
your partition at some number of row
groups or pass in a chunk size and we'll
kind of calculate that on the
you know
inside of desk as long as you have small
enough road groups i think you will be
okay
but of course if you're trying to you
know
approach speed of light then maybe the
fastest thing you can do is to make your
files exactly the size that you want
them to be and you kind of turn off all
the statistics gathering so that
all the ask is doing is just saying oh
we have a file listing each one of these
files is going to be an input an output
partition and that will be your fastest
scenario
yeah it's it's
it comes to the original comment that
ben made at the start which is often if
you
you face a particular problem and you
figure out something that will solve it
like making your row groups bigger or
smaller as it may be
you end up moving the bottleneck you
might not end up actually getting that
much faster
so uh really figuring out where your
bottlenecks are might be the thing like
lots of files
actually works pretty uh
pretty well now that uh fast parka can
fetch files concurrently and you can
aggregate them into
tasks so that your task graph doesn't
get too big but
you might find just listing the files to
find out what's there is actually taking
10 minutes longer than the processing of
anything so it could happen uh that
would be for a remote
so s3 gcseo or whatever that that is
something that happens but actually it
can just if you're running on an hpc or
the local cluster it can just break
because nfs doesn't support
greater than x number of files in a
particular directory hierarchy that can
happen too
so it depends a lot on the system that
you're using
one time i made a data lake that had
like uh seven million files in it and
there were like lots of like 1kb files
so i don't recommend i recommend not
doing that that was one of the slowest
things i've ever done
for optimal file sizes
i did come across this is an x-ray use
case where data sets are often made by
multiple append
and so one of the arrays in there was
time coordinates
but it had been formed by a pending
one-time coordinate at a time so it was
made of
1200 chunks and each chunk held one
individual number
and that was actually one of the first
spurs to get the concurrent fetching of
many things at a time because each of
these chunks if you want to call it that
was like it's 16 bytes or whatever it
was
and
because they were compressed too there's
a single value so probably
eight byte float or something like that
plus a compression header
in each of those chunks
and they were being fetched one at a
time over s3 so you had the latency of
contacting the s3 saying hey i want this
file send me the file oh by the way how
big it is and then you get these few
bites you decompress them you have your
single value
and you're doing this serially over 1200
and it's taking
like minutes
to just construct this rather small
array
how did you find that out martin did the
does the user say this is how the data
is oriented or did you look at a task
graph and say this is really slow i
should investigate more um in the x-rays
our case the the chunking is is easy to
find but
i don't remember
how we knew to look
it was just
yeah it's taking suspiciously long so
i probably use snake fizz and i saw that
it was doing
s3 fetch many times
that's usually how i approach something
like that
we should organize like a materials on
how to find the bottlenecks
it's like all of these tools together to
find
that it's actually a data problem or
your your chunk size not chunk size but
like
you have 1200 chunks of
one data type
yeah so so das provides you a lot of
diagnostic information but sometimes the
best way to figure out why something is
slow is not to use desk so that you can
directly delve into the internals of
what's happening
i know yeah that's actually one thing
i'll mention with the desk versus spark
comparison so
one thing i noticed coming to the desk
world the diagnostic information is just
so transparent
um so like for me like pi spark clusters
were were always a bit of a black box
didn't really know what was going on
uh whereas with desk like those task
graphs that that rick was showing you
can you just really understand what's
happening in your cluster and can
identify bottlenecks easier
i just found
spark to just be
you know they have cluster metrics but
it's just
i just didn't ever find them to be as
useful as the desk ones
so interesting question just came in
about
how much data you can pass between tasks
which is a different kind of partition
size if you like and
there isn't a technical limit
but
if you
if tasks are being run on different
workers
then that data will need to be
serialized and communicated from one
machine to another
or from one process to another that
still needs serialization of some form
so uh
it does matter basque
tries to
move the compute to the data so um
whether something will be copied from
one worker to another does depend on the
size of that data it's one of the
heuristics that's used and ask will try
to schedule
a task that needs a result to the worker
that already has the results so that you
don't have to do the serialization and
copy
and transmit
but it happens and that is something
that is clearly shown in the diagnostics
page
and it will depend on again a bunch of
things it will depend on the amount of
memory you have available and a
communication speed
um it
for shuffle type workloads you generally
have to do this to some extent however
shuffle does tend to chop up your data
into lots of small pieces so probably
the size of the pieces is
is not the limit in that case but the
sheer number of pieces is the limit
um
i don't think there's any particular
extra things you have to think about
aside from memory footprint
so if you copy something then you you
will be using at least twice its memory
at some point on the original worker and
the worker that's
receiving it
plus overheads for turning it into bytes
which can be quite efficient
um so serialization has moved on quite a
lot in the last couple of years so you
you don't necessarily end up with many
times the original memory size but you
might so it's another thing that you you
would want to measure
um but
overall partition size arguments will be
the same as for reading in the data that
you need to care about the size of it
versus the global memory that's
available
um if your machines are not co-located
on on a cluster
then obviously transmit times will be
much longer so you might care more about
absolutely trying to reduce those sizes
if possible
typically that comes down to compression
or a better algorithm that just doesn't
do as much passing around of data
serialization of
pandas
uh does now use arrow is that right
i'm actually not sure anymore
desk has a variety
or broadly answered the question desk
serializes things in a variety of
through a variety of mechanisms pickle 5
aero
it does
some fancy serialization for gpu things
it's pluggable
as well as using the standard pickle
architecture so if you have some
objects of your own that are not known
to desk you can use standard pickle ways
to define how it gets serialized but you
can also submit specific serialization
types to desk so that desk knows about
them and does the right thing
specifically for the case of sending it
from client to worker or worker to
worker
maybe james could you answer the
question on handling s3 connection
limits
yeah for sure so there's a couple of
different so yeah retries is right now
an answer um to your your point um there
are a couple different levels at which
you can retry things so martin can
probably comment on s3fs has
its own built-in retry with exponential
back off or some back off mechanism um
and desk also has its own
independent of s3fs um
back or retry mechanism as well where
you can say hey you know like
run all these tasks um if any of them
fail like keep retrying them up to
user defined amount of times i think by
default it's uh zero maybe um or and and
feel free to retry it up to say ten
times or something like that um there's
a question as to tuning these retries to
make them um sort of
uh
effectively at the level that users
don't actually have to specify anything
manually they just take care of
themselves but yes that's hopefully
answering the question brian
there is also a third lowest level for
network type stuff that people don't
tend to have to deal with but it can be
a problem if you're running things from
your laptop
and reaching out to a cloud service then
you can have
network type things interruptions
whatever
i haven't heard much of people
specifically requesting for that style
of retry
but yeah as i say there is a load of
conversation around this
and ex exactly how to best expose
the communication layer retries and what
they mean and the different kinds of
retries is a an open problem i think
on uh
consistency between types of arrow
versus
pandas
or i should say parquet versus pandas
when you
write using either arrow or fastback a
then we keep we we translate some the
data to parquet appropriate data types
because that's the only way we can get
parquet to store them but we also store
in the metadata of the file a
description of what the original data
type was
which enables us in most cases to round
trip the data perfectly including things
like
date time
zones which is something that uh comes
up
and generally i think works pretty well
as some things that just can't be stored
or some things that are
optional i'm thinking particularly of
categorical data is an interesting one
so
parque supports
what it calls dictionary encoding but
it's not the same thing as asserting
that your whole column is a categorical
type so that is something that we put
some effort into working around
um
das doesn't really have its own data
types it just uses whatever the
python library of choice uses so that
would be the
pandas stroke numpy type system
and the same thing goes for kudifor or
whatever other libraries they they are
mostly consistent with each other
pandas has
come up with a few new data types
recently their nullable data types that
kind of thing that are not necessarily
standard
so there are some
options that we
might surface do surface in some places
or not necessarily depending on how new
they are and how standard impenders they
are
and
that means when you
come across parquet data that could be
represented in one of these types either
you want to you need to add yet another
keyword argument for the user to be able
to choose if the user recognizes that
this is indeed an option or you try and
make a sensible guess
so
it's something we're stuck with i think
and we
try and make reasonable defaults we try
and document the differences and we try
and keep up with changes as they happen
i need to add to that you don't
it's hard to be consistent because
people want extended they want d types
specific for their applications because
they can get some kind of optimization
from it
so for example qdf recently added
decimal 1632
and will soon have 128 data types which
will
just not around for um for pandas but
are is available inside of arrow
probably fast park a can get it
and there's also the other way that uh
you know qdf does not support knowable
data types i believe um
whereas
you know pandas does now and so just
kind of aligning things and assuming
notable data types
in
from the from parquet into pandas can
break things and cody up so we you know
it's hard to coordinate all of these you
know
different etsy types it'd be better if
we could agree if the world actually at
large not not just pi data but also like
or pi data including r could agree on
null handling
they're starting at that level and then
going to
other data types yeah good luck just
talk to the sparse people
yeah and then first
yeah
and i don't want to say anything about
odpc
odbc works over text actually
so that
the
specific database drivers
uh may be optimized and have a more
opinionated view on data types but
anything that sends its data around in
text in json or whatever you will lose
type information when you do that
so it's a
best effort kind of scenario
i don't think dusk itself is in a
position to do anything about that it
relies on other tools
so we have 10 minutes left so uh there's
still quite a few people in this meeting
please
raise your hand type in a question or
whatever um
yeah text i mean it's still ubiquitous
i i i know we we talk a lot about
optimizing for parquet and other binary
formats but it's still true
that csv is
is probably
by volume the the biggest data store of
raw data for tabular data for any data
but there are other things like json and
xml and i don't know what that
if you're demonstrating how good your
data processing system is you wouldn't
use those as your benchmarks but in
practice lots of people have to deal
with them
okay we still have some few minutes but
while the chat can come up with some
last questions i
would like to start with thanking you
for your talk and for the questions you
answered today
i think we had a great vivid discussion
in the chat
uh yeah thanks everybody for being a
great audience this is a
great uh lots of great questions
you